[موسيقى]
بالنسبه الى سؤالكم يجب ان اقول لكم ان
الاماره الاسلاميه التي تتحدث عن نظام
الاسلامي تريد تطبيق الشريعه واحكامها في
البلاد يجب ان تنظم شؤون الحكومه والامور
التي ترععها وفقا لاحكام الشريعه لذلك
تاخذ الاماره الاسلاميه خطوات تتفق مع
مبادئ واحكام الشريعه وفيما يتعلق
بالموضوع الذي سالت عنه قدمت وزاره
التعليم العالي في الامارات الاسلاميه
شرحا عن هذا الموضوع وهو في راينا كافر
[موسيقى]
علينا ان نوضح ان الاماره الاسلاميه
والنظام الذي نشا تحت قياده هذه الاماره
يتكون من علماء كبار وطلاب درسوا وتعلموا
ولديهم اهتمام خاص وعظيم بالمقارنه مع
غيرهم بالمعرفه والعلم والتعليم وغيرها
لهذا السبب فان الكلام عن ان الاماره
الاسلاميه هي ضد التعليم والتعلم هو امر
مرفوض ولكن كما سبق وذكرت شيئا فان
الاماره الاسلاميه كان نظام مسؤول وممثل
حقيقي للشعب الافغاني ترى انه من واجبها
تنظيم جميع الشؤون سواء كانت في مجال
التعليم او اقتصاد او التنميه او مختلف
المجالات الاخرى وفقا لمبادئ الشريعه
الاسلاميه واحكامها
[موسيقى]
بهذا الخصوص لا يمكننا تاكيد ذلك ولكن
نراقب ما يتعلق بالقضايا الاسريه
والعائليه وليس لدي معلومات في هذا الصدد
ان كان اي من ابناء وزير التعليم العالي
الافغاني يدرس في دوله اخرى ام لا ولكن لا
يمكنني تاكيد ذلك ايضا
[موسيقى]